okay how are you made it I mean so let  me just say how dare you how dare you  with that infinity scarf I mean we have  a straight-up daddy can we talk an  infinity scarf yeah like the ones that  they just don't it's like an infinity  pool this is the film that we finally  get oh yeah gotta have the Star Wars  accessories I got the TAT whatever um we  see the trio together finally can you  talk about what that was like so fun it  was just so much fun that this time  around we just laughed so much more than  we ever did not only were we together so  much but JJ shot a lot of those scenes  and wonders so we would do in you know  whole long takes and you could just  really feel the energy and and  particularly working with John boyega  who I just love so much being a lot of  people love you and John well hey I mean  there's a lot of love to go around  [Music]